salut comme tous les mercredis depuis
plus d'un an et demi une vidéo sort à 6
heures du matin sur cette chaîne youtube
mais petit problème la vidéo qui est
prévue pour aujourd'hui ce mercredi ne
sortira que samedi matin
du coup j'ai dit à loïc on fait quoi
j'aimerais bien quand même temps et
quelque chose et loïc tu m'as dit quoi
loïc tu m'as dit voilà donc c'est
exactement ce que je fais c'est pour ça
qu'ils imaginent pas comme d'habitude
c'est pour ça que c'est moi qui la
montrait merci loïc frères voyez ça
comme une vidéo bonus et la vraie vidéo
arrivera samedi matin à 11 heures sur la
chaîne
le rendez vous est pris comme disent les
gens très vieux comme moi vous allez
voir aujourd'hui des pépites des bonus
des trucs qui se sont passées durant mon
spectacle qui sont des impros des choses
qu'il n'aurait pas dû arriver et qui
sont arrivés et comme en général je
capte je mets des caméras pour
retravailler sur le spectacle j'ai ces
moments là et c'est ça que vous allez
voir aujourd'hui mais peut-être même
temps vous dites ce spectacle c'est quoi
force qu'ils en parlent in your soul
avec son spectacle et bien justement le
teaser vient d'être terminée par nicolas
bégué et je voulais diffuse maintenant
imaginez sans chercher à retenir quoi
que ce soit en bas l'intrigué sa femme
il n'y a pas beaucoup de personnages
est ce que tu peux ne dira pas autre
forte audible qu'est-ce que tu es en
train de visualiser entre nous deux
néanmoins l'homme qui a écrit ça il
écrit au dessus des lignes en dehors du
cadre
et ça c'est un signe d'intelligence une
vivacité d'esprit
alors je dis ce qui se passe en bas en
fait il ya alexandre et dorian tous
regardent en faisant les coaches pas de
l'excès mais la question qui me
turlupine depuis tout à l'heure c'est
comment ça se fait donc ce soit tous
retrouvé le même jour au même endroit à
la même heure
et bien moi ce soir j'ai envie de voir
si vraiment l'univers d'un et pour ça
j'ai la prétention de vouloir recréer
ici ce soit le big bang
sur cette scène
c'est donc parti pour ces quelques
extraits qui n'aurait pas dû arriver
durant un spectacle qui sont arrivés je
vous dis au revoir maintenant et rendez
vous à samedi leaké cette vidéo si ça
vous a plu ce petit concept bonus pour
une fois abonné vous si c'est pas encore
le cas des me voir en spectacle si vous
avez envie à très bientôt au japon
gardent bien de quatre façons il faut
pas que je puisse les voir elles sont
bien toutes les trois faces en bas
l'amisom était complexe comment les
skieuses la sarthe est plus simple tu
sais que tu es déjà montés sur une scène
de théâtre
non pas contre attaquer parce l'on veut
faire payer à cause de la perspective ne
suis pas plus petits je suis plus loin
l'ag touche l'écran c'est utile mesure
combien ça veut dire donc que je fais un
net ok donc n'avait jamais fait de
salles de théâtre sur scène je te
présente peut-être de la tour eiffel
saison bon sang quel est votre prénom
marie servent à nez avec boîte m'a abîmé
monsieur les draps oui vous êtes
ensemble
mais d'après il avait la main sur sa
cuisse un an
par exemple marie je peux affirmer que
tu as choisi une carte rouge n'est ce
pas si c'est ce que tout le monde a
compris la blague du dos
tu veux du vrai mentalisme la femme de
ta carte et noir
deux hommes
regardez comment la prévenir en fait à
la al amal à une main a ri et du coup
elle applaudit comme ross dans friends
j'avais comme insulte de plus tu parle
en bien fort tu es droitier ou gaucher
l'at elle me fait voir un moignon ça ne
veut rien et du coup côté d'ankara est
ce que ça va te faire mal si je tape
huila qu'est ce que tu t'es fait ces
indiscrétions ça c'est humain c'est
parce que j'y reviendrai plus tard mais
si je galère avec le bras gauche je
ferai ça sur ton bras droit d'accord non
mais je vais parce que je te jeu de
secouer quoi as-tu anticipe un peu le
mouvement
comment faire pour but d'anticiper trêve
oui bien balisé course pq bronzette
non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
daniela est bien que très belle chanson
sur une vénérable
du coup c'est réglé vous la connaissez
aussi apparemment
daniela a aussi gênante
on s'arrête on a eu un premier satellite
en orbite dix ait ça va toi sinon ses
parents
c'est le papa maman et papa laquelle
devait devants 6-1
voilà une maman avec de la barre mais ok
tu vois je te retiens parce que quand il
est parti comme une flèche pour monter à
dury toi tu savais la gérer
est ce que comme pour toute la tournée
oui 2 cuil si leurs mensonges dans
quelle ville abidjan imagination au top
de table on va faire une ville plus
improbable une ville où tu aies jamais
allé dans quelle ville abidjan à la
panne mais d'habitude quand je demande
une ville improbable où tu n'es jamais
aller on me dit new york los angeles
c'était la panne mais sors de chez toi
jean je t'en prie et en plus de suite
complètement exclue car je ne sais pas
où est la panne je fais semblant je fais
le mec besoin de chine ces relations
c'est à la côte
ok donc de plus comprend rien à cette
univers hockey
est ce que tu peux me dire bonjour et
dont mois de naissance il te plaît à
vendredi
aujourd'hui
[Applaudissements]
maniable l'affairé la lumière témoins
des partis les régisseurs ils sont
tellement généreux à vendredi il était
16h serbe que tu me fatiguer
sari il manque pas un truc là pourquoi
il sait qu'il a oublié quelque chose
parce qu'il sait que déjà qu'il sera pas
payée parce que attends tu qu'elle pose
est juste la pause le là ici mais des
partis ou les parties en loge
la voilà en tentant mais alors
oui non mais attends on va le mettre
discrètement et en plus c'est bien il
n'est pas du tout dans le bon sens tu
peux me le mettre dans le bon sens
stoecklé ouais merci rasées c'est
émouvant de voir son dernier soir avec
nous du coup
en vrai si vous saviez pas encore quand
je vous dis que c'est que c'est mais
bonhomme que ces méga sûr on a commencé
ensemble en autoproduction depuis
toujours et gary dans scanner puis le
lycée j'imagine que c'est une belle
histoire qui va s'arrêter